I'm Jeremy Jones and I am nowhere near
the greatest detective in the world just
stating the obvious here funny because
Kenneth Branagh never really he never
uses a pipe so this is stupid
[Music]
Murder on the Orient Express
so Murder on the Orient Express was a
book it's been many movies I've neither
read the book nor seen any of the
versions of the movies this is all new
to me
don't let that surprise you'd be baffled
at the movies I've never seen in my life
but this movie is directed by Kenneth
Branagh it also stars Kenneth Branagh he
plays hair - the greatest detective in
the world and he's on a train that gets
stuck in an avalanche someone gets
killed on the train so what's up to him
to find out who did it and hopefully
take us along for the ride because it's
the point of a murder mystery first of
all what I loved about this movie this
movie looks great not only does this
movie have a great setup to establish
how smart this guy is but you see the
directing shine through the color scheme
the color palette the contrast you
really saw what Kenneth Branagh was
going for and I really liked what he was
going for also Kenneth Branagh was great
in the movie that's right he has a great
eye for the movie has a great
performance in the movie his character
was fantastic the other characters I
don't know that's when we entered the
flaws man this is a murder mystery it's
gonna be a lot of investigations with
the characters the characters played by
a great ensemble but no one really
shines through because you don't really
find out much about them from the get-go
Kenneth Branagh's character they make a
joke about his name sounding like
Hercules so you know his name I cannot
tell you anyone else's name in his
movies suppose this work Lou has the leg
up on this entire genre miss Scarlett
professor plum Colonel Mustard you know
who they are because of the board game
the characters are here I don't know
so when Kenneth Branagh is just rattling
off information because he's piecing
things together you're like I don't know
you're talking about really and that's a
flaw in the movies part if the movies
going to revolve around information
given from other characters you should
probably know who they're talking about
when they're addressing the information
given from the characters move it just
doesn't execute that well which then
makes the movie feel a bit boring
halfway through this train is literally
packed with characters played by great
actors you should want to be on this
train even well this someone died so I
guess you don't want to be i but you get
what I'm saying and then comes the
biggest flaw in the movie to me and that
is the fact that either the movie is so
vague in its information is giving you
you're not really following Kenneth
Brown
he's doing it you don't feel like his
protege or apprentice you don't feel
like the detective on scene it's like
the movie felt like in order to bring
the audience in on it they had to give
you information that I felt was a bit
too obvious I say that because I solved
it and it's not at all because I'm
Jeremy Jones and I might just be the
greatest detective in the world I know
we're close I'm nowhere near I never
solved these things it didn't come
together for me because I am so smart at
murder mysteries he came together for me
because this movie was a bit too dumb in
its execution is he in a murder mystery
they have to find the balance between
what is too vague and what is too
obvious I don't feel this movie found
what we call the Goldilocks zone for
that but I feel like that's a subjective
thing for me not everybody is going to
get it I suppose but I can't help the
fact that I left the movie theater
feeling a bit robbed because of the
movies execution guys in the end Murder
on the Orient Express looks great it's
actually acted very well but the
execution has a murder mystery is a bit
shoddy it's a bit choppy you're not
invested in any of the characters other
than Kenneth Branagh's character if you
find a book that's like the art of
Murder on the Orient Express buy it it
probably looks great but as a movie I
will say Murder on the Orient Express is
probably a better time if you're drunk
yeah now it's a party all right so
Murder on the Orient Express have you
seen it why did you think about it was
your favorite murder mystery whatever it
is whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you
[Music]